[Music]  easter island isn't the only place in  the world with some mysterious stone  faces  in the highest peak of the eastern  taurus mountain range in turkey lies  nimrud  [Music]  is a temple tomb believed to be built by  the late hellenistic king antiochus  he reigned from 69 to 34 bc and built  the temple to commemorate himself  the monument features statues of the  king  lions eagles and various greek armenian  and medes gods  with each measuring almost 30 feet tall  the heads of these sculptures once sat  atop their stone bodies but at some  point in time they were removed  nimrod went lost to memory until it was  rediscovered by a geologist in 1881  and in 1987 it was designated a unesco  world heritage site  [Music]  and while there are those that believe  these figures hold a deep mythological  significance  how these stone structures were  physically constructed without modern  tools is a mystery  you